okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is what I hope will be a
fairly straightforward meeting wrapping
up some details about cloud framework
form of language version 12 okay so
we're gonna start off looking at a few
of these preserved functions cloud
object name format you see here I'll
come now okay so what did you did is
this cut nearly written or what's the
deal with this this was I mean we kind
of finished this last time and it was
down to you knitting this into you
knitting it and so we so the content is
done here so like cloud object URL type
and all that does that content is done
is that correct I think that's right we
can make a quick pass through these so I
think we're we kind of left it was when
we describe these options in the
functions that use them you know how do
we talk about it in the little summaries
at following settings can be used so
this is deployed view of the object and
then per n slash obj yes yeah and then
this one is / n slash env yes maybe we
should say slash o bj / r it will still
be dead out slash objects at the moment
but that's all right in the near future
it will it will switch over okay okay so
the name format let's just take a look
at this one here this may be a
mercifully fast meeting who's to know um
famous last words
I think we should just copy the possible
you
so come on read it now why is it not
automatic Darla cloud object game format
why is the default not as usually it
shouldn't it always be usually be
automatic I'm thinking in fact what is
it what is it set to use a robot let me
into college it name format I see so
that means if I do a cloud deploy oh
it's the cloud object name format option
default for its cloud deploy is
automatic yes right so this is in fact
called name format is but that's not
right because this look at this the
cloud object URL type its default value
sorry to college it name format its
default value install a cloud object
name format so this isn't consistent so
I don't know how did not yeah that's
that's not right then okay so this
should be automatic here and in fact
what this did I don't even understand
how it did it because it did something
that chorus Ohno it had an obj and okay
that's a separate issue okay so hold on
hold on hold on hold on so it defaults
to obj okay so this is what I would
expect in the case of cloud object name
format is automatic
okay so let's say I say foo and then I
say foo to
okay that's not right that's got a URL
that this should be
look this should be
cloud object named format okay here if
I'm not mistaken cloud object named
format
oops name format should be in this case
use a URL base okay it should look like
that shouldn't it yeah
it's shown there maybe so I'll scramble
this debug it unscramble it okay yeah
so the correct default setting here is
dollar cloud object name format should
be automatic okay
by the way internal folk at the company
might want to get their LDAP names
registered as user URL basis just a
small point typically is what happens I
understand that but we should go up
preemptively before before there's a
land grab no I mean since your account
was created that's what happens okay but
not everybody in the company has that to
get what I'm saying I'm just saying
yeah register all the users yeah I think
so from the LDAP directory okay so
listen I think we know what should
happen here it doesn't seem that it is
quite happening but let's get that
straightened out yeah I think it's just
this build this this works in other
places but ok what will it fix this ok
all right now
knitting ok so we probably want a Oh
first of all hold on a second let me
just check one other thing which is if I
go to the cloud object page
fine okay
okay
you
you
you
you
where do we talk about cloud base in
here I don't know let's find out maybe
we don't okay so hold on a second so
then let's add a thing here I see this
is functions and deployment and
execution metadata is yeah that's what I
was thinking of
okay so cloud object locations and
naming okay
you
so here
should we give the defaults the the
dollar sign variables or should we give
the
know the option symbols let's say dollar
cloudbase where there is a dark cloud
base isn't there yes the cloud
okay then we've got I know that we can
list these in tremendous detail
um
you
because I think most of the time it's
just going to do the right thing for
people yeah okay so then we're gonna say
here um cloud base
and dollar cloud object URL type and
dollar cloud object name format arguably
us should be in the other order
okay now this should probably go to
let's see where is my
content of the cloud go
this is definitely where this should be
going
okay
you
you
okay I should link there okay
what's this cloud object naming okay so
that's the part that we didn't put it
that's the part that we're now putting
in right it sounds like it okay I don't
remember what cloud object rules was
going to be the tentative thing there
yeah okay
okay so here we forgot cloud base
we have mentioned cloud base here
oh the option name right I'll go with
Matt first of all this should be first
okay that's red but then then we should
say
I arguably think that this is more
important and that this should go down
below
I didn't see where you gestured which
thing is more importantly I'm hold on
hold on mm-hmm okay wait a minute this
should say
you
okay cloud location now
you
you
do we want cloud connect up here in this
section
you
or do we want okay so here we want to
say cloud base
you
okay so here
you
um okay so here we want to say
dollar cloud object
what is it format name name format okay
whether to use
you
you you IDs
use a
names etc for to name cloud objects
you
you
um
okay now
have dollar cloud object URL type
um
you
you
okay now we've also got user URL
the name of the user what does it use a
URL base right yes and that needs to be
in you know I'm not gonna put that I'm
just gonna put that and listing here um
because that's going to be in a
different page yes what does it use a
URL base yeah okay okay now we've also
got
cloud execution metadata that's a
different thing
by the way when are we gonna get these
other things that are here user agent
name user agent language and so on I
think we just have to document them I
mean they've been around really it's if
they're not document if that's why
they're in black yeah
well that's it there's no in pink here I
see how they say user agent name user
agent version and so on do we really do
we really pause the user agent strings I
don't think we have we've had a user
agent parser there since the day one
yeah really well so if I say cloud
evaluate yeah it's in your cloud
evaluate dollar user agent string well
so you're gonna get from here you're
gonna have a user agent string that
doesn't provide all that stuff if you
make a request from a browser that has a
user agent string that has a lot of
interesting I could just go to the cloud
right I could go to the user agent
string I could go I could make a an API
if I say cloud deploy that's that's how
you do it yeah of an API function of
Adelaide of dollar user agent string
yeah and then you've deserved that in
the browser where your well doesn't
matter if you're logged in if you make
it public okay that's just the raw
string and then you know the various
various things some of these things
assuming have that as an example on the
user agent string page can you check
please I'll check this thing here yeah
okay so now you're telling me that if I
say user agent name for example there so
let's say I say
some of these fields aren't really
filled in when you visit from a desktop
browser there's more information when
you visit from a mobile device the
things especially things that talk about
operating system but yeah yeah okay so
that was blank that the the thing that
has some the user-agent languages was
blank I'm not familiar with so that one
may be new to me this is all getting
kind of funky that's probably why we
haven't documented this stuff I mean I
think we'd be better off having an
association come back that is the I
think we should call it user agent rules
or something or user agent data that
would be much better than than this I
think yeah fine and then just bring it
back as a bunch of rules I mean it's
gonna come back in one blob anyway yep
and then just say um should we call it
user agent data or user agent rules
Dana would be similar to the HTTP
request data but that's a function isn't
it ah true I see I mean unless we want
this to be a function user agent data um
agent information because that matches
someone's like the cloud user
information that we've looked at well
it's not dollar cloud user information
it doesn't exist yet I see but is that
going to be a function or is that going
to be a variable I would think more of a
function that's a function because it
takes a wolf a cloud user ID as a query
oh I see what you're saying
um so maybe it should be user agent data
as a function I'm not sure it depends on
whether it's really gonna all come back
as one blob or whether this thing
requires processing I mean for example
some of those geo look ups might require
processing the user agent data it really
just is parsing the string and seeing
what's not you know if there's any
information to be known from that
there's well user agent languages might
require yeah that's true
well okay so provisionally I think
probably user data user agent data as a
function I think also the code will look
fairly clean if you say user agent data
of quotes browser type yeah you know and
it returns you know whatever else yes I
mean the other question is whether it's
returning entities yeah this is getting
complicated because you'll want a second
argument that determines whether it's
returning the thing as a string or an
entity okay and that's we can just make
for the hell of it let's just make a
function page just to a future eyes
function page
you
you
you
yeah and so this would
um you know return either R or strings
or entities eg browser types all right
and I don't think there's exactly the
highest-priority think that this should
be on the list this thing had to get
developed um
you
okay now we're still looking for where
we put user URL based
I aware aware as cloud user is it
already in the execution metadata I'd
use the URL base yeah think so I don't
think that is um let's look at what
dollar cloud user UUID is and by the way
[Music]
oh it's a nerd section thing called user
identification oh wow that's future eyes
that's really weird it is in the
execution metadata page under
information about authenticated users a
wise this future eyes this page
was an created in September
something goofed up here
okay Matt we need to unscramble what
happened to this was created by me and
and and September okay
you know I'm looking down if you scroll
down a little bit I wanna see this it's
probably guessing there's things here
that we haven't done yeah there are
there are some things that haven't been
done okay yeah I thinks it should still
be useful though yeah beautiful stuff
here yeah
okay yeah please figure that out okay so
this needs to go by the way the using
URL base let's check yes it does okay
you
all right
you
you
can you get that information about
authenticated users
well that use the URL base how do you
determine oh that is here yeah that's
well yeah okay okay all right fine so we
didn't hit that bad and my question is
how do you set user URL based that is
it's created automatically when you
create the account and then you can
change it in the web app in the you know
account settings okay all right okay
fine okay anything else we need to
figure out here the only thing is the
setting the default setting for the
dollar cloud object name format I still
need I want to check if automatic is
going to work or not why wouldn't it
work that's what I need to check it's
just something is telling me to check
that okay all right fine well if there's
a problem with it you gonna let let me
know yeah what do most dollar variables
do in the system well I'm what they do
they're their defaults but things all
right no what I meant is are they
typically set to automatic or what
situations would they be concrete values
I think that they're usually not set to
automatic because um because usually
they're kind of the end of the line of
what what's going on but I think this is
a case where it's well defined what it
means to have it be automatic so to
speak that make sense which is to pick
UUID if it's unnamed and user URL base
otherwise yeah correct and if they
didn't set user your elbows then maybe
there's a different case there that that
should always be said
there will always be a value for that
they're sort of triplet of user
identities and user eight URL basis sat
along with the user ID and the user UUID
okay fine okay and the thing else we
need to figure out here
could you check the cloud deploy page I
want to see the option table where we
talk about this cloud object name format
and cloud object URL type the some gosh
these are future eyes hold on these
things were future eyes died didn't
notice that these are not some you know
say I have to have a I have to say
something which we should comment on to
the the doggie tools team I think that
the skis colors are not bright enough
mm-hmm they're blending in right and
include definitions is that is that also
a it should be stable that should be on
futurist well but doesn't have its own
page yet well let's look at manipulate
okay so that's important there and those
by the way should have been twelve
pluses um okay we better look for other
things where that might have happened
shoot that was in there on wires
cloudbase not D future eyes from
the cloud beta cloud base is funny for
cloud object because if you look at the
usage the very last usage there's a
cloud based second argument that's relp
a thin sea base the very last one yeah I
don't see why we shouldn't allow both of
those yeah deploy let's chitchat cloud
publish
I'll [ __ ] miss sake what happens if I
do that now
great KD future eyes whoops rise D
future eyes
you
a few tries okay
you
okay and now
well we better look for cloud object now
I don't even know how to do that pelagic
name format hold on one second
okay card published I object to
cloud save oh gosh
now this was a goof up I'm glad we
caught this
you
you
you
you
Wow how many more of these are goofed up
you
you
all right
you
you
child objects
has a cloud object name format of that
correct I I think it's supposed to here
we were just discussing that today code
but be sitting here there huh
you
okay so what should i do should I not
yet be future eyes the cloud objects
case I think we should put it in because
it's going to be if it's not already
there it's very easy to add object URL
to yes okay it was the URL type we
needed to add that makes more sense to
which to this to cloud objects yeah okay
so this one is already there yeah okay
great um okay anything else here okay
okay
anything else yeah that's all okay so so
long as we can get this to happen
automatically correctly with this
working right I think we're in good
shape
fine I think that I didn't realize you
were here but that's that's your thing
presumably to get that straight
do you see any problem with it okay
great okay
nothing else no that's that's good for
now okay thanks a lot
alright see you later okay bye